you guys should be live I am currently a
now I am now I'm in the classical shield
arena this is a ten hour along
tournament which started just over an
hour ago
I'm not gonna play the whole thing but
I'll play at least a few classical games
and we'll see how long I can survive um
I do want to thank everyone for all the
support over the recent months and weeks
almost been one year but thanks everyone
for helping me reach 3000 followers
anyway let's let's get into this game
let's play e4 let's be aggressive
opx 17 total not good to see you Nathan
thank you
Samsonite Jennifer - good to see you
guys so this guy has just over 10
seconds to move Carol Khan what do I
play against caro-kann probably the two
knights attack with Knight f3 and Knight
c3 this is uh this is an enjoyable
opening to play
each six with novelty
age six is interesting because
quite often people will play Bishop f5
which is a mistake but h6 might prepare
Bishop f5 that's being tricky with move
order
I mean the most logical move is just to
develop like Bishop c4
yeah let's play Bishop c4 I mean White
has three minor pieces developed and
black has nothing developed I just want
a castle Castle rookie one probably d4
at some point
you
just to explain why Bishop f5 was a
mistake earlier it's now it's not a
mistake unless it is
there's a very specific way white can
take advantage of it
you
so the standard move as my g3
- here to play Queenie - with the hope
of 97
I can't resist Queeny - please play 97
after the game if I remember
the Bishop a5 immediate immediately and
show why it's a mistake
what is this room thing what room thing
are you talking about
Jakob puppy
room thing
you
I'm not going to accept challenges
unless somehow I fall apart in this
tournament but I'm gonna just continue
the tournament as long as I can so he
plays u6 this is the best move
now maybe I'll still play my g3
for
let's play d4
there are some cases like if he plays
Bishop e7
might look to play Knight g3 Bishop H 7
and 9 H 5 or g7 could be a target
there's some other ideas where
I might want to Castle queenside like
Bishop f4 castling queenside and then 95
in g4 there's a few different approaches
for whites
got a message about joining rooms
I don't think I initiated the message
there is a sub only room which I don't
know I don't think is too active
um but subscribers to get access to the
the subscriber will need room so b5
some of it
Bishop T 3
III
let's play Bishop III
the board visib d3 could have led to a
lot of trades if you were to play an out
of six
villager good to see you
mornings good my recent streams have
been evening streams but
decided to wake up in the morning to
to try and do a stream
let's see how my morning chest compares
with my evening chess
- what silent castling I'm gonna play
Bishop to f4 because d6 is somewhat of a
hole also yes toilet noggin is right
there will be sub giveaways
who's Eric who's Eric with a k'
maybe maybe that's autocorrects fault
as far as I know there will be subs
given away at random points throughout
the stream let's go for 96
you
cuz now okay he has to take I'll take
back with the bishop
the bishop hair and I'll have a monster
Bishop on g6 and then he can't castle
controlling the dark space
hmm he has two legal moves here
Bishop's 86 in kingi 787 I just went out
five
so this is 20 plus 10
meaning this game can go beyond 40
minutes
doesn't I'll move quicker
mrs. Persson how
while stirring goo you're early
you are early just started not too long
ago
um so ideally I would like to keep my
bishop on this diagonal the problem is
if I play this or this it runs into a
five
and that could be could be really
annoying so I think I have to love him
castle I'll just go back to f4 and enjoy
my bishop hair
and there's actually an idea here if he
were to castle
even if he doesn't Castle I have an idea
of g4
looks crazy but
can't take it
treats I have some pawn break
some eventual pawn break
g5
you
I will say that I have liked a good
number of like Russian and like European
friends and a lot of them will spell my
name as er I K which I had to get used
to
I think they did it intentionally not
not accident so if I play a g5 you would
play h5
so maybe I should play h4
I mean okay geez
five
[Music]
I'll start with h4
I'm being a bit ambitious because my
opponent is low rated but I feel like
this is a perfectly fine way of playing
my king is completely safe my rook wants
to stay on one of these files and I just
want to break through at some points
like he can't really ever play net of
six because then it gets it with g5a
drew Ascencio I'm doing well or if it
sounds really nice
Louis weather's hot here gray foxy
thanks for the follow
I'm a bit disappointed I did not
identify who the 3000th follower was
also did you just hang up on Bishop to
e6
it opens e-file so I don't know if I
want to take it
because Bishop to e6 communicates and
he's threatening me rook e8
so maybe I should just play g5 first
you can take and attack the bishop twice
in f6i I can't imagine this a good move
but I have to be careful with how I deal
with it
I could very easily get into trouble if
I take on e6 right away g5 I don't think
works
so
I'm thinking c3 Bishop c2 but I want to
keep the pressure on e6
I could probably just get away with
winning upon there's a big e6 King h8
means I Castle rookie eights
and then I take on g7 or something
[Music]
you
there's also a line okay let's imagine
g5f tg5 Bishop take you six King h8 and
then like Bishop e5
you
[Music]
just seems too weird
I would like to be controlled
okay so the other candidate moves I
could Castle queenside I could play a
four light d2 could be interesting as
well
just remove the night
it actually makes a lot of sense 92
because if he takes on g2 I might have
Queen take you six King h8 King take d2
five
ninety-two I take you to
I mean maybe just can take t2 then
there's pressure on you sick or queen
take two you too
I'm attacking you six I'm preparing g5
let's go for that
not the most exciting move but I think
it does the job
hello Chester Amy good to see you back
the problem with box position one big
problem this night is just it doesn't
really have any squares
and this night doesn't have much
supports
so I think he has to take and then I
have to decide can I get away with
taking you six
but the plan is to take with the Queen
also King GM thanks for the follow
I'm drinking my usual tea Nathan my
usual mug it's great tea Egyptian
licorice it's like naturally sweets it's
probably my favorite tea like out of all
the tea on the planets
you
but I'm not sponsored by them I just
enjoy the tea Kuwait 95 I did not see
coming but I mean now taking on e6 looks
even more attractive because after King
h8 I take here and I'm preventing
Roorkee AIDS yeah this just wins a piece
I'm threatening to take on c6
d2 is defended
if the e-file ever becomes dangerous I
have bishop III in many cases
looks like a London where a bishop was
put on c5
you
I think there is a Bishop on c5 as a
bishop on that for though okay I can
take this continue winning material
and then
I mean there's a few different moves I
want to play one move the c3 another
move as bishop taking four so this is
nice
another follow
I don't know what the name was they're
the followers that are coming in too
quickly but thank you everyone
rook take tea for okay so if I take with
the bishop on e4 he takes back I I don't
lose my queen because I have Bishop III
but c3 I mean the tax of rook is nine
distillate Act
seems like a no-brainer
actually one thing I'm realizing here
you might actually have a very strong
move
my up I'm a a piece currently I'm a
little bit scared that he has a strong
move here which I'm not gonna say
no he's probably not watching
because I started the stream right when
the game started so that the stream
isn't detected yeah he plays a strong
move
it's why you can never get too relaxed
the issue is
I take back and he takes I have three
pieces hanging
two pieces so it shouldn't be a problem
just dealing with with complications
option is to play this counter-attack
like night p3 and I take you to tonight
take a five I take a four wait that's
equal material though so I think I have
to take
carelessness maybe I can take and then
just castle
I'll be up a piece for a pond
you can take either bishop
okay I have to save the rook
castling seems most logical even though
I've expanded so dramatically on the
kingside
might be three is also possible
things the safest option
now again he has a choice which Bishop
to take I'll be up nights
whichever Bishop he takes the other
bishop will defend so if you take son c6
I'll play like Bishop g3 and if he takes
on f4
play Bishop XIII
oh wait anything better ship III is a
move
[Music]
you
let's play Bishop g3
wait a minute he's threatening Bishop d3
but then I have Queenie III so Bishop g3
Bishop d3 Queen III it should be okay
have to be very careful here hey
secretaries
thanks for the sub whoa Nathan with the
sub gifts
Nathan
so many people getting subs I think a
lot of subs will be giving away this
dream is that's my
methyl Eagle lot of new names
okay I know there's questions in the
chat but I have to focus on the game
first because positions getting a bit
messy there's a couple options here to
either play Queen III or Queen c7
it's hard to focus with so many subs but
I try my best so Queen III um prom with
this is it actually no it leaves g4 and
defended but he can't take it
so Queen III he would probably play rook
here and then the Brooke is attacked my
pawn is attacked
okay so Queen III rakov T it Knight to
f3
Brook tech g4 and then rook FD one
it's still okay there
let's go for it
you
I also have a move like rook
fc-1 which I kind of forgot about but
this will attack the Queen
defend the rook with tempo
and then maybe somehow I can defend the
g4 pawn
so can the screen do any damage
like he'll just play Queen but if you
play this Queen d7 that I play rook c7
and takes on g4 and Knight f3 that would
go for that play rook c1
like objectively white should be much
better here extra nights but the fact
that my kingside is weak I feel like
it's gonna require some accuracy
hello to more people
hello yeah swine roots offense so many
more people today Queen d5 windy vibes a
move
on g4 so f 3 would be the logical
continuation
thanks for the sub scorch scorch search
stir fishy at that
okay so if I play Knight f3 he takes on
g4
that's annoying
maybe Queen f3
trade Queens if
- a bishop efore thanks for the sub or
be at some point I'll just have to
ignore the subs and then focus and then
think them later
anyway Queen f3
I think all the lines look nice
so I'm happy to trade Queens
trades and winds upon I'm happy Bishop
e4 can't be played
and I'm defending the pond
so I assume he's gonna move his queen
but I'm not sure where he's going to
move his Queen to
a lot of squares
you can move here here here
but if queen g7 or Queen f7 I have rook
c7
if Queenie six probably have Ricky one
I'm taking advantage of the facts okay
he's gonna win the pawn
about to say I'm taking advantage of the
fact that if he wants to win the pond he
has to trade Queens
so he wins upon but now I have some pin
this looks nice
no tactics that I'm missing
you would love to play Bishop e2 but the
bishop spins
and there's some simple ideas here one
simple ideas rook t2 or KD 1 another
idea is 91 so life is good
okay so he plays rook d7 because you
probably wants to play Bishop f5 which I
don't know if I can stop
so I'll just play Brooksie one
and then after Bishop f5 the
to take and play Brooke c7 and start
winning pawns can you do a freestyle rap
about twitch prime yes but not now
I have freestyle rapped before but a
requires a very specific environment and
this is not the environment to do it
okay so you place kimchi it
so I could play Brooks III and just for
fish about five I could throw into check
probably isn't useful at all
maybe this
five and then I'll take and I'll start
all at least one day seven pawn
and 99 it's got I'll just enjoy my tea
in my position
you
okay so I'm going to win the pawn and
then I'll have
a night for a pawn
have any past pawns
sometimes issue of these positions is
when you have so few plans left
if he trades off the rest of the pawns
it could be very difficult to win so I
have to avoid trading pawns ideally I
would like to just trade pieces
Bishop c4 I also like to improve my
minor pieces
rook is fully optimized let's play 92
just tickle the bishop is there sugar in
the tea there's no sugar in the tea it's
just hot water and a tea bag but it is
naturally sweet which I like I am back
in the US I'm in st. Louis I've been
here for about ten days no about two
weeks I'm here for a while recovered
from jet lag
let's just keep attacking the bishop
setting up some small trap if he plays
this I play this and I'll win the pond
he plays that I can trade
- I want to trade
[Music]
trying to figure out like if we if I
trade the bishop and
we trade the queenside pawns
be winning for why it's just might be
annoying
because I'm just gonna play King no I
can't because the pawn is hanging let's
just play a three first
just to see what he does because I'm
realizing his rook is pretty stuck and I
might just want to play
the scheme maneuver to f3
I did break 3,000 people I broke 3000
followers but I didn't break them
literally
unless
I did something terrible that I don't
know about a five is a strong move
actually because he wants to play off
for maybe now it's time to take
wait is that for a threat though because
I have worked d4
three
Kim G to F for Brooke D for
I think that works I also have King F 3
in that position after f4
trying to do some sort of decent
technique this is a tournament this is a
leach historic classical shield arena
my first game it's a 10 hour long
tournaments okay he plays that for this
should be good now cuz I have this
upon ooh wait a minute but I play Tripti
for he has f3 that I can take with the
night so that's ok
Stewart's
I'm not missing anything
I'm not sure how long I'll play I'll
probably play until
until I got tired
today is my day off working from working
at the st. Louis chess club so I don't
have any huge commitments and I'm not
playing blitz cuz I know a lot of people
I think enjoy classical chess at least
that's the feedback that I've heard Wow
so he's kind of trapping his rook but if
I attack his rook he has pawn h5
guess the threat is to play pawn h5 and
then my Bishop is pinned
what's going on here maybe I can take
just take care
you
it was a very strange position
and there's a few things that can happen
okay if he takes with rook I take the
pawn I'm happy if he takes with pawn I
have to be very careful because in that
position if I take the bishop he has f3
check and he wins the rook he plays h5
but I think he forgot I could take care
now this is this should be pretty simple
methyl Eagle fueling positions like this
more you trade down especially pawns or
the more you trade pawns the greater
drawing chances he just resigned well I
was trading pawns to win pawns because
if he were to take here the plan was to
play King f3
when you add Bishop e6
um anyway okay it's unexpected
resignation I want to show one thing
from that game I just want to show the
opening trick because I feel like this
is a great opening if you're an e4
player to play against caro-kann I've
had I've had the line in streams before
but essentially I usually caro-kann main
line if white has a pawn on d4 and this
Knight is still on g1 then Bishop f5 is
like the main line for black but here at
Bishop f5 is a mistake because after
Knight g3 and Bishop g6 light can just
start targeting the bishop and there's a
funny line after h6 95 Bishop h7 I can
play Queen h5 forcing g6 and then Bishop
c4 Queen can't be taken because of mates
so e6 would be played and then very
simple move Queen e2 life I've had this
position many times I've I've shown the
students who have had this position many
times and the great thing is that White
has a threat of night take a 17 Queen
take a 6 so there's a lot of moves for
black like Bishop g7 a lot of natural
linking moves which just run into this
and I take f7 tactic like all of these
moves for black just don't work so it's
a nice opening trick my opponent didn't
fall into it he played h6 but I was
happy with the position then things went
a little bit of stray I guess I should
have expected some kind of compensation
for black but when I played c3 I
completely forgot about it Knight takes
c3
maybe c3 is still a playable move
perhaps I should play Bishop e3
avoiding the tactics anyway let's uh
let's go back to the tournament 390
first place
the goal is not to win the tournament
the goal is just to have some clean and
instructive games maybe to play some
aggressive openings I'll also take
opening recommendations re see one play
please King gambit or scotch game
I think I'll be black next game at least
that's probably least statistically
like me color I'm not gonna rap now it
would require several more wins
someone recommended Slav I'm gonna play
e4 and then I'll have to decide between
a scotch or a king's gambit or an
exchange Roy
play the same opening I just played but
against the French so I'll play if he
plays d5 I'll play Knight c3
you
he's thinking all-nighter three is maybe
not the most common move wing gambit oh
I could play the wing gambits
[Music]
no I want to have I want to enjoy my my
comfort zone
I like this opening of tonight's attack
it's so pleasant to play
like opening for beginners to start out
with I just recommend like King's pawn
on e4 e5 learn how to deal with fried
liver learn the four Knights for black
very soon I think I'm gonna put together
like a video series on openings I
recommend for newer players and
effective openings of the amateur level
because I will admit that I have a whole
opening repertoire designed to be
effective against lower rate of players
I just need to
organize everything and be able to share
it an effective way
you
anyway this is still mainline Queen play
thanks for the follow
or is it quipped play font is too small
so
some options here he can take the pawn
with a few different things he can play
this move okay he takes with the bishop
so I'll continue developing and a theme
in this variation is as opposed to other
variations in the against the French I'm
not too concerned about keeping my
Center pawns I'm more concerned with
having good squares for my minor pieces
so all my minor pieces are happy and I
have slightly more space
notice you put slightly more emphasis on
opening with common advice is more
important to focus on tactics training I
mean I put more emphasis on openings as
I just enjoy openings but I think it's
important to have a balance especially
if you're looking to improve your game
you should be focusing on okay tactics
opening and game planning strategies
there's so many different areas to focus
on what is h6
probably scared of Greek gift like if he
were to castle I would have taken my h7
and that would have been fun
I'm gonna play H for year I think this
is a very common move
prevents any sort of g5 and I might just
want to play h5 and even some idea like
rook h3 work g3
you
a six so he's moving as pawns he's
playing a waiting game
could play h5
you could even play rogue Age 3 right
away
you'll play yeah maybe I'll play rock h3
it looks weird though you might actually
be threatening this move to attack the
pawns
there's a very specific reason why Asics
prepares Queen b6 Queen b6 earlier I
would Castle and then if queen take me
to I have night b5 but now I probably
have to watch out maybe I'll play Queen
e2 them
a gang gang Shivan thanks for the 500
bits that's a new name appreciate that
okay so now beat a left is defended so
if he attacks b2 I can probably have
some way of defending
a crappy one
Einstein e1 hello
it's hard to keep up with a chat like I
try but I know there's a lot of
questions coming in that I'm very soon
I'll have to do some Q&A stream or
something so he plays Queen b6 so he's
only attacking one pawn
defendants
I'm considering just castling here if he
takes the pawn Knight a4 or queen a3
I should probably defend
you
yeah I'm gonna play rugby one
so another 500 bits
thanks so much King Shivan
not seeing that name before
this position is weird cuz like neither
of us want to make too many commitments
at least for a block he's low on space
and when he played h6 he's actually
making one of the common ideas less
effective like black usually wants to
play f6 in these structures but f6 is
now just to weakening because I would
have bishop g6 so
not sure what he's gonna do here
I'm also not sure what I'm gonna do I
mean I'm probably just gonna continue
with this plan unless you does something
crazy
and I'll have to react to it what about
95 ah this would be crazy
um that's too crazy for me I don't want
to calculate that maybe it's a playable
move but it's losing a piece and black
probably survives like night 85 you take
D 5 e 6 and Knight f6
there's enough fuel for the fire I think
someone asked a question earlier if I
play okay so if she asks a question if
you play advanced variation is it good
to put your knight on c3
I guess that's what I did in this game
this is not technically the advanced
variation I don't know what we call this
it's just a different type of variation
I guess it resembles advanced variation
well the whole point is that I'm not
reinforcing with pawns I'm I just trade
it off when he plays C 5 and then Ivan C
3 is that's a nice developing square for
the knight so he plays my T 4
that's actually I think a strong move
just because
if I take he takes he's already
threatening some stuff I have to be very
careful what else can I do
good take take then I could take on d5
one thing that works so
take d4
maybe 91 let me as Queen c7 coming I
might be in trouble here actually
so many subs
subs okay well I mean I'm he stay
focused and not get too excited
a knight 84 bishops 84 any other moves I
guess I could play Queen d2 but take
okay 984 Bishop to 84 that's forest
probably should do it right away but I
just don't see the continuation
to not lose something cuz I'll move my
night
see seven
my maybe I have Kim D - they're humans f
-
you
can I take D for bishops 84 King d2 ugly
move
to take f2
but then I file open
have fun
let's go for it
because the problem is when he takes
back he has two threats this is obvious
threat and this is a threat
because it's not that much supports so I
have to somehow focus on how reinforced
tonight
also considering this movie one
then Queen c7
then I take on d5 and play e6 things get
really crazy
okay I have to calculate
wait no Rick do you one just quintic be
too
King d2
take on f2 or
one
I should have some compensation there
I'm just gonna play king d2 not what I
was expecting just a few moves ago
but um I think my king safe I'm D to
like the center is relatively closed
my pawn on e5 will survive because Queen
c7 I'll I'll have four kg one and then
otherwise
hmm wise it's playable if he takes takes
anyway thank you - thanks to the new
subs
and things toilet noggin for for gifting
the suds thanks to Nathan and toilet
noggin I think we have over 10 to 15 new
subs today
did I play been flying gold on this
stream yes I did
I've played him several times I think
he's beating me every single time he
always Sox exchange and then somehow
wins it's frustrating
you
you
why didn't that Castle kingside I
completely forgot castling kingside was
a move
I it just didn't cross my mind I
probably should have considered that
because then I would be threatening rook
to that I would be planning rook e1
I wanted more support of my night but
castling made a lot more sense well here
okay I'll play rookie one
wait can I okay taking on d5 is is on
the verge of becoming a serious option
but I still can't play it because this
bishops not defended so let's play rook
e1
you
actually I guess no the King serves a
purpose on d2 because if i castled Queen
c7 rook e1 he could win upon with Bishop
takes c3 but okay that would be yeah
that would probably be preferable to the
current position happy for his coming
whereas a monster threat
or is it I just move my nights
I just feel claustrophobic
back here he's gaining space on the
queenside maybe I could play like 91
maybe even something like Bishop h2
preparing f4
so Bishop h2
or even bishops III
this is interesting I'm gonna play
Bishop g3 I just want upon coming to f4
I also want my Bishop defended and I'm
gonna hold off on saying anything more
than that because there's
there are ideas in this position which I
don't want to say out loud
strong possibility he's watching
so this is a okay rapid and classical
over 5,000 rapid games that's incredible
500 classical games so this guy plays a
lot of chess
I glanced with the chat someone saying
Bishop take b5 which probably doesn't
work because he has an intermediate
Bishop takes c3 so b4 is actually what I
was hoping for and it's one of the
reasons why I played Bishop g3 is now
that the bishop is defended this Knight
take d5 idea might actually have some
purpose still requires calculation as
after take I can play e6 attacking his
queen and attacking the Knights and
opening up the file
I think this is strong
to calculate just 95 you take t 5e six
should be good enough
yes sir is one variation
you
have to be a little bit careful
that should be okay positions can get
messy because the center is opening up
and we both have our kings in the center
I earn hold off from from saying more
than that
you
so he basically has two options that he
has to like when a five is what I was
expecting
that's what I had to calculate before
playing ninety five and I just assumed I
could play this with ideas of Knight c4
and if he plays b3 I play this you could
take and I played okay one
you
could get pretty weird
but I'm currently off upon
when I back
someone's saying angelic Jake saying
they take before fork come on dude
and I take v4 was a move I don't know if
it accomplishes much after Queen a5
maintaining the pin cuz if I played
before Queen jk2 maybe I should have
considered that but I don't think it
would have worked out c3
so just like sack back and open the king
I have my eye on different types of
works mainly night Forks or if you were
to sit like take on e5 then you could
run into Knight c4
so watching the stream makes you want to
play but you're playing while watching
which is probably not a good combination
because I don't want to distract you
from your game if you want to watch you
should watch and not play or you can
play and then watch later
so probably be on YouTube
you
well I think I still have initiative
like even though he can get initiative
b3 c3 take here I don't know
although Maude
Thank You messy Marvin for dealing with
although Maude
how that just got
I do see some analysis maybe maybe it's
a bit more complex in this line I wanna
like analyze stuff from the past but
Queenie for was a move but then he could
take on c3 he gives back the bishop he
takes on a - he should be able to save
it maybe he has to flavor k7 that would
have been a messy line
something could analyze very
very possibly after the game
so it's a good sign he's thinking who he
takes was unexpected I guess you didn't
want Knight c4 though
to take with the Queen
I'm guessing he'll play b3 and win the
pawn
could play kini to the kini two could be
a lot more comforting and then just run
to f1
- I play rook 81
you
yeah I'll go for it
if I get my King to f1
do I want I could play rook d1 a couple
moves here where I was about to just
play some automatic move but I guess
it's important to identify the options
with rook t1 open file
now Rick eight ones probably still the
best move
want to give them any sort of weird
promotion tactics
and someday I'll win the Chum in a pond
might require Bishop c4 but I'll be
patience
or castle by hand
rook b8 okay so he's attacking upon
guess he's threatening to take it
so there's a few candidates like it
three I could play Queen D for Queen D
for just looks really attractive to
centralise a queen I guess he would then
have rook before
I can go into d6
so queen g4 work before queen g64 tick
b2
strange position
hours of Queen c3
I could be nice
so 24 repeat for Quincy's they should be
fine
if you ever castles I think I'll have
Queenie for provoking g6 and then like I
can start attacking the fish at age six
or h5
so okay let's start with this
or that noggin will be listening but
can't monitor the chat wellthanks toilet
noggin for being around being so
generous and also I appreciate I think
we might already broke in a thousand are
not a thousand a hundred subs which is
another milestone but I don't know the
slub counts maybe moobot knows the sub
count
ebrill welcome back long time no see
count-o ninety-one subs okay
move out it's just confused by that
so it is actually equal material which I
kind of forgot about
but very soon okay I'll probably win
upon
the bishop hair King is happy
pawnee 5 gives me more space love a lot
of things to be happy about
angelic Jake you don't have to ask me if
you want to sub to me and Bernard
squared thanks for the sudden yeah you
don't don't really need my permission
why don't I stream on YouTube i streamed
on YouTube twice but I did like in real
life streams so I did I just streamed
from my phone cuz that was easiest you
just like click go alive and you just
you video with your phone so I streamed
on a kayak and I streamed on the
mountain but I haven't done a chest
stream on YouTube because I haven't
gotten around to the technical aspect of
it probably at some point I will
to do it pretty sure people in the chat
can help all the other subs can tell you
how to sub
yeah Gabriel I am accepting new students
but I have a busy schedule so the best
way is to send me a message and then I
can usually get back to you with my
availability there should be a command
for more for more information regarding
coaching
you
so it's actually a bit surprising the
time can actually be a factor in this
game in though it's a long class well
game is below 10 minutes which in other
games feels eight minutes feels like a
long time in classical chess
it's already approaching time trouble
if you wait maybe
can write your YouTube mink
my description
hey angelic Jake figured out how to sub
thanks angelic Jake
okay so this bishop is actually a bit
powerful
you
blockings rook Queen d6 looks attractive
but I don't know if it does anything
before is a move
you
I'm king of wine also very playable
yeah King f1 why not
problem for him is that his King is tied
down to the Knights which I'm actually
wondering if I can exploit some way
play rook team one sooner
I'm playing f1
simple move
you
have I played b4 before
probably at some points whoa he sacks a
night
is he trapping my queen
or do you just forget tonight is hanging
here rook to AIDS only move as Queen e7
you
it's
g5s but then I have f3
always play f3
okay Queens 87
let's do it
I'm assuming it's a blender but maybe
it's some sort of like deep deep
tactical combination
he was probably so focused on the fact
that he had to prevent Queenie for he
forgot about his Knights that's my guess
cat Queen e7 only move
you
so I'm upper piece
okay he's gonna try and poke at me with
Queen d5 I can even play rookie for
there and then rook lifts
as Bishop b4 runs into Queen c4
so it's been a tricky game
at least the like the opening stage was
tricky after he played a 94 like this is
uh
maybe sweat a little bit in this
position was weird
but I think he's made a few mistakes
allowing night 85 and allowing of course
Queens 87
I did not see your tweet to me last
night cool guy I turned off Twitter
notifications because it just notifies
me about like random people tweeting not
to call you around the person it's just
like it was too much I would get
notifications like every every few hours
and it was um I just had to uh to
disable notification so I checked
Twitter every few days I'll probably be
checking it more during this um these
events in st. Louis though
okay so now the question is do I play
off three three looks great why restrict
is Bishop great room for my bishop
this will have Queen a3
whenever I want
you
I went through a phase where I was just
turning off notifications for all my
apps because it was just it was too much
because I'll get messages on like every
single communication platform I use
which is a lot of different platforms
and then it was it was affecting
productivity so but I will check Twitter
very soon okay so he's not resigning
he's attacking me to win a three looks
very natural
except my queen on e7 is preventing
rotate b2
so maybe just Bishop f2
one bishop f2
I'm just a happier square for the bishop
too much purpose I might be threatening
something like Queen c5
five is going for the trade of Bishops
was playable to play rook d1
could train
he pins
okay I'm up a piece I shouldn't this
shouldn't require too much energy let's
play Queen a3
should be enough
I'm happy to trade Queens also I'm
looking forward to winning made to pawn
it's been there for a long enough he
didn't play rook take B to because I
would take on square rights
oh wait no the brook wasn't hanging
I just assumed that rook was hanging but
the Queen can move backwards so he could
have taken on b2 I wonder if I would
have seen Queen take d8 before playing
Queen take t8
maybe is mutual blindness or maybe he's
watching and he heard he couldn't take
on b2 so he didn't take off p2
you
give me a big shout out after you won
your clubs oh you won the tournament
congratulations that's awesome
congratulations cool guy and thanks for
the shoutout
well that's what do I take with I'll
stick with a pond keep this defended
if he takes we'll trade and all we need
to
[Music]
classical chess is tiring this is only
the second game F to conserve energy
already out of t check some Twitter
Starbucks happy hour at 3:00 p.m.
remind me at 3:00 p.m. for Starbucks
happy hour
okay I'll ring
beautiful
have not had Starbucks in a while they
have good advertising Brooke b3 I forgot
about that I think I can take on a six
wait a minute
let's let's calm down here
sexy takes on b2
I take on a - he takes on g3
kim ji-won
be fine
you
because kim ji-won i'm up a bishop long
as he doesn't get too much counterplay
everything's defended here
might have threats of this
also have threats of this
you
afraid of saying tactics while streaming
um I avoid saying like very critical
lines that my opponent wouldn't find
otherwise but I'm usually pretty open if
I'm just saying some variation like I'm
usually I usually try and be aware of
what I'm saying and how it could
potentially help my opponents in many
cases I'll just say what's going on it
should not help the opponent too much
like here when I discuss what I'm about
to do he can't stop it
so like I'm about to play Tripp do you
want I think he's gonna play Queen c2 we
can trade stuff
Queen c2 is knowing
maybe rookie 3 he can't stop her III now
I win more stuff
simple tactics it took took a little bit
too long there it's a fine rookie three
but anyway
make him resign hopefully
okay he resigns good game oh I don't
want to go back let's pause I just want
to look at one moment from that game
Laveau [ __ ] because there's a moment
okay obviously I should have considered
castling I would think stockfish
approves
castling because kinky - I should be
doesn't look backward for whites but
then later was my take before playable
someone was suggesting this it is
playable wasn't the best move Wow it's
the only move to keep the advantage at
least according to sock fish yeah cuz
ideas of c3 and Queenie for like
something like this and then Queen goes
back Queenie for and
like even in this position assume this
line happens work a seven would be
played black is really awkward in his
equal material but I assume there's some
advantage okay
hello passed pawn 99 I'm doing well
staying alive how do I go back to the
tournament's joined okay am I satisfied
with my London 8020 course I was happy
to go through the process of making a an
eight-hour video course it I'd put a lot
of effort into it probably took about 50
hours total to prepare everything so II
for this game oh maybe I should have
played d4 just talking about the London
well maybe I'll put a scotch if axe
villager is still here let's play a
scotch I assume he just wants a normal
scotch axe villager let me know if
you're still here
let's take we have a normal scotch
cuz it's not gonna be four nights this
is going to be there's a few options for
a white I can take on c6 or you can play
Bishop III or I can play Knight b3 I'll
just play the main line some tactical
threat of of this ooh
d6 is not a good move is he's going to
get triple pawns I used to play the
Scotch like several years ago and this
is one of the very first lines I learned
when studying it
and I remember that whatever video I was
watching they said ninety-two planning
night be three and light is good
- bye - toilet noggin thanks for
sticking around I'll see you in the
future thanks for gifting so few subs
today and the day before uh let's Castle
queenside these pawns are so weak I just
want to play Knight e3 with check
you
I think I can get away with my III here
because if you take something for I play
rookie one
yeah there's not too many opening traps
where the point of the trap is to give
the opponent triple pawns this might be
like the earliest trap I move I move
seven triple bonds I think white is
winning at least upon yes he could play
this you could defend everything
still be happy maybe I then play 95
hissing if 97-95 and he has trouble
defending that car Maura
thanks for the hundred bits they always
play off three now this is attacked and
this is attacked and he can't defend
everything
can someone view the London content I
have a few London videos on YouTube if
you type my name in in London you should
find them I think the most popular one
is the same for this video I also have
the course I don't know if there's a
link for the London course or it might
be the London command maybe nightbot
moobot will deliver
there's a YouTube channel command
there's a discord command - you guys can
probably find my social media just using
the commands
okay so life is good
yes to retreat the bishop
play Bishop e6 whoa you just walked into
a fork
do I take the night do I take the bishop
or do I do something else
I think I would play Ricky one here
now he's pinned he's forts he's tripled
up life is good
the bishop and then take the night being
extra greedy
I still want to take this pawn
you
um for twitch yeah regarding subs and
automatic renewals if you subscribe
using twitch Prime it doesn't
automatically renew
if you subscribe the other way I don't
know
think it does I think you have the
setting of whether to do it
you can cancel in your settings
he resigns tough game it was a great
opening trap I don't think I've ever had
that like even an online game see how
many people have had this chest Bay in
the chat hello chest Bay thanks for
answering technical questions yeah if we
go back to like even this position d6 is
a blunder positional blunder it's been
played over 1,500 times for anyone who
plays this is black you should know that
there's a couple moves to play there's
Queen f6 and Bishop to b6 both of these
are are very playable but this is a not
so playable 92 not the most popular but
I think it's the strongest okay compact
to tournament that was a quick game up
join we
- I lose the game
oh it probably started a game
that's bogus I just lost 51 points
because it started a game without my
knowledge
how did it do that though
to go back and see the replay
because I thought I went straight to the
Alice's board but maybe I went to the
tournament
or maybe I had a new tab open well there
goes my tournament score am i rating now
I'm tilted what is this guy's
see three he wants to play a Ponzi honey
but this is a weird move order
just want to win as quickly as possible
and go for the kill let's take like what
is this line c3
no let's take on e4 first with idea that
when he takes back I have Bishop c5
guess that's playable but I've d5 here
I've won all my real games so far but
losing a game by not moving that's a bit
tilt inducing now I have okay now I have
Queen h4 g3 take green f2 9.5 I think
the problem with that is after this g3 I
take g3 is Queen to e5 check so I think
he unknowingly just set up a trap or
maybe knowingly I don't know the Queen
h4 doesn't work so I have to move the
knight he's gonna take that I have to
move the knight again so let's just move
the knight to
where do I move it to
yes you can kick it around for a little
bit I'll play in 96 he'll probably take
with pawn and I'll play Knight c4 he
takes with Queen okay let's play Bishop
u6 now I'm happy I'll continue
developing and the e-files open it
spawns on f3 okay let's play nice e6
you
you
you
and maybe
let's just continue improving the tempo
tilted I think tilt is by definition of
temporary mental states
but maybe for some people if they have a
really traumatic experience
I play Bishop e7 or can I be even
trickier
there should be sevens just hoping for
g4
but actually there's some points to it -
maybe Bishop g5 in Bishop III is some
idea
okay let's castle
happy to get the bishop here and he
wants to castle which I can't really
stop
or can I
[Music]
thinking about inducing g3
doesn't make much sense
play Bishop d3
there's a d3 rookie let's do it
see two suggested by Jake I don't think
so
why did I only play five games yesterday
in the rapid shield as I stream
yesterday
maybe I did I had to go i had phone
calls and
and just lessons
I'm gonna play rook e8 my threat is this
and take advantage of this or just win
this
you
you
it's hard to play like a whole
tournament especially these shield
arenas they just go on forever
you
okay now the plan is to win as quickly
as possible start with Bishop III and
then go for Queen h4
you
as night as almost traps he has to move
back and then I'll play Bishop f4
am I going to play in the sink felt cut
well if someone drops out and they need
an alternate I'll be around once
Anastasia's mate well this is this is
means I think Anastasia's made is
something like where you lift the rook
you sack and then you mayn't is that
right that wouldn't be me because 9h
five maybe there would be some idea
brookey six was playable but I didn't
see a defense for lights maybe he can
play this actually after Queen f2 I
could take take and then play rook e1
and then it's just mates anyway back to
tournaments
have to recover
recover the rating after that's that
mess up
our Xuan is buzzer King Oh berserk back
why not we'll have a rapid game
but classically rated
Bishop c4 play this
the euro saw gambit I played against
this other day I play d5 with decent
success he just pre moves when this is
pre move
- expecting g5
so confused
maybe he's done some preparation for me
I guess I have to take the bishop and we
get some weird position or I'll have
double pawns but I have the bishop hair
um not sure how to evaluate this I don't
think this is too bad for black
start with Bishop e6 I would like to
play c6 in b5 get Bishop d2 seems
passive let's throw in rep g8 improve
with tempo and then okay now he wants to
play f4 so let's play c6 restricting the
Knights now he wants to play f5
so let's play I fight myself
and now let's play b5
he's playing very quickly I feel like
he's about to blunder
oh no he's not plundering I wanted to
play b4 in Bishop d5 but he has some
d-file stuff so maybe King she eats her
King c7 laking c7
he blunder
Bishop g5 appears to win material
so before
night ce2 bishop
you
the problem for him is I play Bishop d5
it just traps at rook use at the very
least losing an exchange I think you can
either play ok night h3 is a move
do I take
because I love my bishop but I'll take
it
now he wants to play Knight g5 and
attack the pond so I'll play h6
and then the plan is to complete
development you like a trade
by trade I could take first
96
that looks decent
I'll gather Bishop to d6 but it's okay
expecting Bishop d6 King b6 and then
I'll maneuver my Knights to somewhere
happier maybe throw in a five
b3 he's tempting me to play c3
looks very attractive might be
overextending but who waits chess
Spanish thanks for the follow no hablo
mucho espanol
yeah a three
you
wondering if I can just take and if he
takes with Bishop I play c5 and then
Knight b4
you
anything else they see five immediately
let's take
you
strange position pawns are equal
maybe I'll bring the night to b5
actually if I bring the night to be five
his bishop is okay now he's attacking
CFI so maybe I have to play Knights east
six wanted to trap his bishop
at least okay I restrict his pieces
whoa okay I can play see for now
what is he doing with his night
maybe I just play King clicking beef
his bishop is completely stuck
why not
play rugby 8 maybe you're a t8 first
karlof is king
or knocking b5 first
you can sack the pond
Bishop will be stuck rook da will come
very soon
this is a fun position
- you interrupted - probably
that's okay I'm up material I like my
position c4 is very explosive
Knight p7 so he wants to play Knight t6
I can play rook d2
thanks for the comments chest Spanish
there will be more videos coming shortly
to the same Lewis Channel
one
you
you
considering just sacking
96 is coming
maybe I'll just take on b4 so I don't
think he wants to take my rook
you
doubts ooh he takes it now I have some
nice defended pass pawn on the second
drink this is a fun position I have a
passed pawn on a file just start pushing
maybe King a3 maybe rippy eights so many
options
94 let's play 94 defending at five
and there's the threat of this
this is a quickest way to meet Brooke v8
is coming
I take C to
as a feel-good ending
hanging after 96
Oh
true
mmm-maybe I would just take it and play
up the eighth give back the exchange
I forgot c4 was hanging
96
he made four and Knight takes e4 maybe
that would also be playable
like rook d4 or something as Evans
gambit good for beginner it's very
playable effective opening a lot of
players don't know how to play against
it
okay I'm on the verge of breaking in to
the top hundred
do I recommend an e-book about strategy
I mean reassess your chests covers a lot
of great
rates to treat strategical motifs
there's also a book chess strategy for
kids by Jeff Coakley which I like to
recommend that would be for players
probably 1,500 and below Danish gambit
for whites if he plays e5 then maybe I
can pre move d4
unless
I wanna play clothes Sicilian or Grand
Prix he plays a six
I have to play g3 he plays g6 let's play
h4 I had this position just a few days
ago
h5 is already annoying for black
I will play d3 usually once once you get
the pawn to h5 you just want to keep the
tension and wait until they plunder
like now maybe h6 those where's the
bishop moving Bishop f6 I have Queen f3
maybe I would play ask for though
it's yh6 looks fun
mmm he takes
the dark squares are there bound to be a
problem for black
it better be a problem
and I moved all pawns of
I move my night
I think it's probably about time to
start moving pieces
you
debating whether to allow some Queen
trade
to
good option
I'm thinking that yeah Queen f3 I'm
really disobeying opening principles
like moving the H pawn so early bringing
out my queen out bringing my queen
before the rest of the pieces but the
idea is so play Queen f6
if he castles Queen f6 is just about
meeting
if he takes on e4 I've play Queen f6 he
moves a rook and then I probably just
take back
you
please respond which
on two
to go up I've been slightly ignoring the
chats
gambits in the Sicilian the wing gambit
and the one where you just play d4
you hate Sicilian and you're looking for
a sideline I mean they're very playable
if you're playing against a strong
player sometimes you're just losing a
pawn and you're not getting much
compensation both the wing gambit and
the Smith Mora I wouldn't Sarah the most
sound openings but and then the level
below mm they're they're good sidelines
I would say
I probably have to trade Queens I didn't
really want but what to do
let's take
I still have my dark-squared bishop
this will be the MVP and if you're
looking for like a sideline against
Sicilian I can highly vouch for a Knight
c3 Sicilian you avoid the open Sicilian
variations you play on your own turf so
all the pieces are on are on the first
and the eighth-ranked so what to do
fella ping let's play Bishop g5
okay now his night has no mouse
a Castle queenside get the D file
and both of those nice are stuck f6
loses a pawn you should have listened to
Feingold
now I'm going to play you five
was the pawn sacrifice
night to escape let's play at four just
restricting his night planning to
reinforce the bishop this king is stuck
in the center plane out of three
who's gonna say it's gonna it's hard to
win the game quickly after a queen trade
so early but I might try and organize
some mating attack
you
mm maybe starting with e5 or even Bishop
h3
- wait there's options here I want to
lose my H pawn
I'm gonna start with e5 most ambitious
move first stream you've caught
when's the next time
Oh when's the next time I'll do co-op
analysis I don't know actually because I
don't have any tournaments but maybe
I'll play I'll play Illinois open in a
few weeks and I'll do some kind of
analysis there but Coast you won't be
there unfortunately and gangue shivoham'
thanks for another 500 bits
you
always coming out of nowhere
okay so he 1997 is actually a good move
because he wants to do this and this
make his pieces uh better
to manage my time too
eh too
[Music]
so annoying
I have an idea I'm gonna play Bishop to
h3 I'm gonna try and tie his Bishop down
to d7 and then
we'll see what he does maybe he'll play
like 95 or something
at some point I might even sack the sack
to get more activity
for tactical reasons okay so 95 was
expected but rooked 85 might actually be
non a sacrifice because I have e6 this
is a good move
v6 is coming 9h - looks cool night eh -
too late
this looks even cooler
for rook my bishops very much enjoying
life
this is attacked he just resigns at
tough game
normally when white plays h4 against
this g6 setup black should respond with
h5 so and that was his first mistake in
allowing h6 I think this is already
tough
maybe he should just focus on like maybe
even castling queenside like start with
b5
that's another thing normally when you
play a six on move - you should play b5
next move almost no matter what
okay back to tournaments it's almost
noon I've been streaming for about two
hours
happy hour isn't three hours I do want
to take a run at some point before then
okay first time playing against e4 today
um and there's been an opening that I've
wanted to play about having gone against
t4 we'll see if we go into it
he plays III I wanted to play the
Cambridge Springs
no one's allowing it so we'll play some
sunny Slav and we'll play this a six
line slightly less common but um this is
a fun variation there's lots of ways for
white to
perhaps go wrong or for which black
should just equalize this should already
be equalizing maybe I can put the bishop
on g6 because the problem for white this
bishop is just stuck h3 so this bishop
is also kind of stuck
just castle put the rook on the eights
I'll do the Spanish maneuver during the
night to g6
I don't think he should play e4 because
it would give him an IQ P so I'm just
going to continue
Cambridge Springs losing for black um
losing is a very strong word it's
probably slightly worse for black
if white knows what he's doing but I
think it's very effective at any level
below like 1800
it's come up in like in GM play my
Carlson beat gal found with it in one of
like the main lines
and got the fine position from the
opening
you
yeah so the plan is 96 some point I
might play like Queenie 794 try and
create some attack
100 bits from do doctor or doctor
thanks to dr. more videos will be coming
out shortly does he really want to play
e4z for Hertz's d4 pawn and there's a
pin
let's just play Knight g6
f-for
I think just loses a pawn you forgot his
rook is undefended
but do I take with my bishop her my
knight probably the Knights
you
I think he just didn't know what to do
there like he got some structure like he
develops and then what usually white
should go for the minority attack in
such positions and usually white should
have helped the bishop before playing
III
but even like okay we play the main line
going back to this position b3 is the
most common move to try and play Bishop
b2
okay so he's gonna fight I could take
the bishop I could just leave the whole
pin situation
you
to do
hey it's a donation so we'd Urbanski
thanks for the five dollars first actual
donation of today Gotham chess in the
chats
okay I'll still try and provide
instruction so Gotham chess can learn
I'm just looking for a candidate moves
here I mean I could simply take and be
up upon I would like to keep the tension
and build up pressure I guess I could
play Queen e7
Queeny seven might make sense
I'm gonna keep it simple and then I'll
play actually maybe I'll play 94 and my
queen will go to more exciting squares
and this Bishop is sad bishops happy
this bishops happy blocks up a pawn I'm
happy night take H 3 says Jana you've KZ
wait what time is something oh I could
have I could have gone crazy insect but
I'm not that insane wait do I take with
I'll take with pawn
you
I was about to say his dark spheres are
weak but he has an item f1
so let's improve and keep initiative
always nice when you can just improve a
piece and make a threat in this case the
threat is this
probably has to do this
it's hard to mate when his night is on
f1 a rookie six looks attractive
yeah let's play rookie six times a lift
Gotham just like to rip take you for is
that a move that's the possible move I
just like having a pawn on e4
other donation from alt tags easy thanks
for the five dollars okay I want to play
nights or I want to UM I want to play
Queen take night checkmate
so Queen g3 he plays a night back to f1
so I have to be tricky maybe I'll just
play rook h6
been lifting as much need to rock left
yeah let's play brick
rook g6 -
that's better
so I'm not sure if either move actually
has a threat
rook g6 ties down his queen
yeah let's start with this
because now his queen is tied down
still trying to figure out what I'm
gonna do next move
like if if he just plays this what's my
plan
one
well now he doesn't have night off one
so now I can just infiltrate
and this is trouble that worked out
nicely
of destruction there
I'm so focused on meeting ideas I went
dreaming pausing and playing on the
queenside that's true
things happening on the queenside now
the question is do I take his nights
I just let him resign okay a nice game
yeah I just didn't know what to do in
the opening and then just gave me a pawn
and then had some attack rook take e4 it
was very possible
yeah I don't know
were possible let's let's move on moving
into the future it's one minute before
noon who will win the sink fold and the
rap in blitz my money is on Carlson
forcing Feld cup rapid and blitz it's a
big toss-up
probably NACA I would yeah I would have
to put money on NACA knockos good
applets
I am curious how Fabi will perform
though
I know he's okay he's in training for a
world championship and curious if it
will have a positive impact or maybe
he's just hoping to hide all his walls
preparation but round one starts
tomorrow so I'll be exciting already
been seeing some some big names
throughout the the area skies
provisional
is okay he plays let's see please okay
what do I want to play
play Sicilian
super tank fire and the chat I haven't
seen super tank fire in a while okay
let's play my normal opening play some
kind of whoa what is this
it's play 96 actually some sometimes
play this is white it's a very playable
line and he's know he knows what he's
doing here like Bishop e2 is if I play
to his knight c3 runs in 294 so it's
like I'm playing against myself
you know whether a move is another
donation yang Schiavone
thanks for the $10 I'm gonna play g5 I'm
pretty sure this has been played before
by Judit Polgar I remember his looking
at this position and it's a cool move
because I want to play g4 he's playing
really quickly
I want to play h5
Bishop g7 and control the d4 square
g5 is not a move that you'll see every
day but I know this has been playing it
like at top levels and it's not one of
my keys
crazy blitz or bullet moves this is I
think very playable in classical chess
leads to a interesting looking position
too
each three
seems like he has no fear
she wants to you just wants to win a
pawn
I already mess up and I think this is
all playable
have to sack up on like I might have to
play g3
maybe I can take and play h4
okay taking and playing h4 is my first
first instinct
when the G for adore and then I have
Queen h4 in the end
with some compensation
but I think this is reasonable
only problem is
take our lawn out of three
that could be annoying
but maybe it's okay
I'll just play like Bishop g7
for still okay let's take
takes with rook up to h4
be queen g5
there's options here Queen g5
either three Queens AG to rook g3 Queen
h1 rook g1 Queen h3 that could actually
lead to like repetition which I don't
want okay let's just play it for
very strange position
I haven't really developed he's moving
quickly too which is unsettling
I think Bishop g7 is a logical move here
threatening Bishop g5 so Bishop g7 makes
a lot of sense to target the b2 pond
there might be some setup where my
bishop is happy going to f6 and my
knight comes to g6
you
now he's thinking which is a good sign
I'm not sure what he's going to do here
is perhaps several different options
lays ro8 thanks for the follow lights
III normal move
I'm very tempted to play 94
Bishop g5 could be a threat
so maybe I have to play Bishop f6
which is a move I kind of want to play
anyway
Bishop f6 might be five looks annoying
then I just played d6
let's start with this
I guess it was important my bishop
defends the rook some of like g3 I can
always just take and meanwhile I would
like to complete developments hello
jimster 99
good to see a lot of new people today
okay he attacks upon
now maybe 94 94 we can trade stuff might
be 5 in the end Ariel with a sub
welcome back Arielle thanks for subbing
this position is so weird like it takes
energy so they come up with reasonable
moves
94 mr. plate e4 pawn to d4 Knight b5 I
have like Queen b6
okay
you
in some cases where he plays a five
which have been annoying though so the
solid option here would just be to play
d6
which looks very intuitive but he might
want to play d4 next
trade everything I've queen f6d six a
week in the end
wait a minute if I play d6 I don't think
you can play d4 because I have some
tactic against the rook involving e5
okay let's play d6 solid move defend the
pawn see what he does
did I play g5 this game I'm missing a
jeep on for anyone who just joined I'm
playing an opening which I'm pretty sure
I've seen before this g5 move I'll have
to to verify it after the game but
it's a playable position leads to very
weird weird situation for both of us I'm
taking a lot of energy here to figure
out what to do
so far I feel relatively comfortable
Queen d2 is a natural move
now the question is can I just play 97
everything's defended and then go for
Knight g6 even if he plays Bishop g5
I'll still go for Knight g6
looks okay
you
though he might he might be just
planning to gang up on h-bomb like
queenside castle and rook h1 and then
hopefully there's some some queenside
compensation for me
like castles I'll have some attacking
potential with Queen a5 / 94 or a six b5
so it's very possible
at the Rosen gambits Lissa's in the
gambits at least yet material is still
equal okay so he castles I'm gonna play
Knight g6
because where else is a night going I
guess I could consider 94 and night ec6
but I want my night here now I have two
defenders of the rook which could be
important like if he plays rook H 1 and
G 3 I could still take it so these
pieces defend the pawn and the rook
this could very well be my last game
because Starbucks happy hour is in three
hours and I want to take at least a one
hour run
day is going by quickly
and I need to charge my phone
my phone with my mic and my webcam
plugged into my computer because I lost
my wall charger
life is difficult
you
from total something-something thank you
g3 just thinking about g3 that I could
just take it
I think I should just take it
unless there's something better also did
I forget
I could play e5 sadly five in some cases
but he would just move the rook back
okay so a CH Cyg g3 you
he could take on g3 with the record of
the pond
I think I'm happy to trade off the pawns
like that's relieving the tension
now I no longer have a weakness on each
for
you
yeah let's take with my bishop yeah
because the bishop is effective even
from the corner light would not be so
effective from the corner
now I should probably complete
developments or just launch an attack
the Queen a5 is an option
so I probably want to Castle queenside
too
395 he could play might be five and then
we can trade Queens and I play King g7
maybe I just play a six first because b5
is a very real possibility
and then
be fine let's play a six
b5 and h3 was interesting I didn't want
to play e5
because it severely weakens t5 and it
makes my bishop super depressed and to
attack the room for one move it would
not be worth it so I'm I'm leaving my
pawns here to restrict his pieces the
plan is to play d5 and opens open one
file either the a or the B file
I might even be willing to sack a pawn
if I can play b5 and he takes twice it's
not even a pawn sack because I went a 2
in the end so that would be nice
nb5 works well with my bishop on 8/8
like if I gather up to be a play b5 they
work on being in the bishop on gates
they coordinate pretty well against this
b2 pond Eric your pawn structure better
I mean I have one pawn island that's
like the least amount of islands you can
have rice unless you have zero pawns
so
also target that seven with my g5
in worst case scenario I have 95 in many
cases
that is a bit annoying
well okay let's imagine b5
wasting no time he plays my g5 now I
play Knight GE v
night is good it just bought my bishop
but it defends things
it attacks things
yeah I'm gonna rely on some intuition
here and not necessarily calculate
everything
maybe save time for more critical
moments
and there might not be an immediate
threat with v5
if I want to push or take I just want to
leave tension maybe build up the tension
with this and this Thank You Prime show
for the follow
so I'm curious what he'll play here
because it's a tense position
we're both trying to improve our pieces
I still need to complete development
like these pieces should all find better
squares
so one potential
I can make is to play queen 85 and b4
and then remove the night and win the a
pond
looks decent enough
the one piece that feels like has no
purpose in the position this is Bishop
on c8 though
every other piece has purpose
navel in some case defend f7 my other
pieces can help attack okay well let him
think uh okay now I have to think my g5
I mean 95 I don't see anything wrong
with I guess I also have vision f6
but that could be a
run into 97
so now
five
let's do it
now one move I forgot about
I'm just realizing now as Bishop here I
don't think it's a huge problem because
I'll have Bishop f6
or even like rock a7 so it should be
okay
just have to watch out like this is a
major my major weak spots
like positions like this especially with
my king in the center in his King on the
queenside it's important to focus on
both attack but also difference
you
jimster with the comments
I'm breaking a lot of principles I know
I push my Jeep on early it was all with
some purpose like it's move 18 I'm still
having most of my pieces on the back
rink
well it's sometimes in chess you break
the rules sometimes it leads to bad
things but sometimes it can lead to good
things there's always exceptions to to
breaking the rules
and in this case I still feel okay like
obviously when I play g5 my King doesn't
want a Castle kingside
I don't think I want a Castle queenside
I want my rook staying on one of these
files
and the center is still closed for the
time being I remind you of Yasser I'll
take that as a compliment
I was talking with yasser yesterday so
maybe
I picked up some of his calm mannerisms
but yeah Yasser will be in in st. Louis
doing commentary or the next what from
the next two weeks three weeks so he
plays Bishop h5
which actually leaves these pawns less
defended
I would want to consider
counter-attacking
my first instinct was Bishop f6 which
could still run into 97
so maybe Roque 7 is a way to go
it could get really messy a crook a
seven he could take twice on b5 I win a
two and then he takes on that seven I'm
not sure what's going on or Bansky with
another $5
thanks for Bansky okay let's try not to
get distracted
time is running low okay seven I might
just have to use intuition I also have
to realize actually Queen f2 is tragic
for him after tonight tape d3 okay so
Rick a7 jp5 take b5 take b5 or take a -
I'm threatening rook a1
that should be good enough
if I play bishop it at 6:00
nine eight seven Bishop g7 Bishop g5
that could be really annoying so let's
play rock a7 my rook has some defending
or defensive purpose but also some
attacking purpose
so
always useful to find multiple purposes
for pieces as long as they're not too
overworked
I brought I broke 3000 and reading yeah
that's why I had the doc I thought just
for some suspense
anyway I was talking with yasser
yesterday and um I was on my laptop and
he came in and he was telling how I have
me chest open it was saying all these
amazing things about me chess and
recently he's been like challenging
stockfish in these crazy house matches
he's showing me one of his most recent
crazy house gains it was completely
insane
I'm sock fish just completely outclassed
him
it's always nice to see someone like ah
sir just playing on me chess
okay anyway let's focus on this rook is
guarding f7 you can't play queen g3 I
want to focus on I want to at some point
get the initiative which might happen
very soon he might be going down in this
crazy variation take back
Wow so it's happening
maybe he's watching maybe you decide and
calculate and he's calculated further
than me
I just thought this is so risky for
whites I mean it's also risky for a
black
but okay rook take a - a cheer from
always beasts thank you
yeah this is actually scary because t6
is a weakness
but let's calculate okay rook take you
to and I take f7
he also has kim b1
kimby one could be a problem it just
could be the end of my fun so rook take
a to king b1 I'll start with a b2 is a
targets
maybe then I can play something crazy
like
they take d3
or maybe night see for particularly to
King be one night see for he winds up
seven
but not with check I guess you could
just take on c4 we trade everything on
b2
yeah he's probably better in that
variation
I could also play rook b7 here just
attack the knight keep the defense of
the pawn
and target the b2 pawn
if these lefties Rick take a two lines
don't work then rook d7 is a very real
possibility but I'd like to make
something work
maybe five doesn't work okay so look to
go to King me one
a knight 94
right in Queen a size
if they take up seven
five
discovery checks
that's so crazy I don't think it works
for or black I don't know why but just
it seems way too risky
Brook take a two-key me one night before
night I got7 Queen a5
is so many checks like night a key five
Knight rook infiltrates
actually there's a king da roca fakie me
seven and rook rook use mates I think
you
something there's much else to consider
yes I'll play rugby seven
be files now open
and down the pond but feel like I should
have some some initiative
because now the files of
the diagonals open is two nights
obstructing the attack of the beep on
the threat is very clear to take on me
five so you might play a four
you
I have night before
I also have c4 ideas crazy move but just
trying to open the position
like a 4c4 could bleed to craziness
you
night before it would be a more
controlled move
I still have Bishop f6 possibilities to
you
whoa more subs from Nathan things Nathan
chess philosopher Kings gambit quality B
arc zero tram stir something okay this
is not a time to get distracted this is
very critical moment
yeah a force a strong move I think
that's my movie I can generate
initiative here
like before
or c4 or even d5
he finds a booth
five
I just don't like my position because
his pieces are better than mine
you
my Queens tied down to do
six which is very annoying
maybe I can play 97 looks strange but
playable there's also 94 which doesn't
know their pong sack which could also be
playable
June 94 looks interesting
to try and open the see file
yeah I don't have much time but I'm
gonna go for outside this move
cheapo threats let's start with this
it feels wrong but I feel like it
relieves some of the pressure
and there's also cases where if he takes
twice his bishops no longer supporting
the Knights and there would be tactics
involving for example in I take d3 in
winning the night on g5
and now I'm prioritizing peace activity
and attack a lot more than pawns
which maybe not the most sound approach
but we'll see how it turns out
might break uh yeah we're very close to
100 subs we're in the 90s I think in the
high 90s
Keith Patrick the number two
shir eath Patrick is back welcome back
Heath infinite flash chest okay now is
not the time to get distracted with the
chat or anything else I have to focus
like this is a craziest position I've
had all day
just such chaos
I guess the position suits my opponents
username pretty well that crazy guy
he's only played one rapid game
so he plays a la blitz
there's a lot riding on this game
when I I should break 2,100 if he wins
he breaks 2,100
I don't think I've ever been more
motivated to break 2,100
it's good he's thinking I know my bishop
on c8 is my worst piece what to do maybe
someday it will come to life
I can't even like develop to d7 is and
it would obstruct the rook someday it
would dream of coming to a6 and applying
pressure that could take a while
you
I should challenge John Bartholomew
yeah I would love to do like
collaborations with other YouTube people
and streamers that will happen at some
point it's just about logistics but over
the next like two weeks I'm I'm probably
gonna have some collaborations I guess I
can go ahead and say this now I was
talking with Yasser about doing some
some stream with like Sarah wine chess
it was actually the one that suggested
it which would be pretty cool
and there will be other other popular
streamers in town so we'll see
don't think there's too many options for
white here as I have an immediate
threats
as he could follow the wisdom of and
Feingold
then his king is aligned with my rook
so he takes I take
wait a minute there's there's another
candidate move here I can't
can't play too quickly I can consider
this move I don't think it works
even though I would love to play it
I don't think it works because he can
play king b1
and then a seventh undefended I still
need to win the piece back and then my
night my nights hanging yeah I think I
have to take
was one idea though it's now an issue is
my bishop doesn't have scope against his
pawn but the C files whoa what does this
move is he about to cook about to
destroy me
that coming that could be very strong
though
so he's sacking a piece
he's getting a massive pin whatever I
take with
this is bad because he's gonna attack
the night and then t6 is gonna be
undefendable
the rook maybe it makes sense to take
with the rook because I'm at least I
keep the pressure on d3
he's going to go into each six
and then I play like ki7
maybe I'm alive
as I think I can eliminate night take
like if night take weena for
or even
like mmm this is bad I feel like there's
gonna be a lot of different wins for
whites
but what to do I'm gonna play the move
which I think gives me the most hope
I'll see what happens
you
problem is night is so so annoying
constantly attacking d6 which means my
queen is tied down takes with bishop
interesting
now I have two pieces for a rook
he still has initiative
attacking a d6 pawn and my Knights will
only move his queen e7 I think
it feels like I'm sort of alive
he does have a lot of pawns still
who I have queen g52
he has a night 86
that's bad
play Queenie seven larrya's increments
so I I could get low on time and survive
or anything else
I don't see anything else
we need seven maybe my dream will come
true of getting high Bishop to a6 very
soon
also my bishop wants to come to e5 right
oh no I just didn't see that so I was
probably just losing then that was a
very strong sequence that's sad
I won't resign Zev two bishops
and maybe his might get sort of trapped
unless okay unless he finds oh he
doesn't find it okay I think he should
have taken with rook
what happens
are not even threatening to take the
night
that's really unfortunate
here
take off seven would have been simpler
because then he he would have real cafes
in the end winning the bishop
winning a bishop
it was very strong game by him I have to
retreat
hoping for some miracle though like his
night is still a little bit restricted
I'm hoping for Knight g5 also doctor
thanks for the sub 99 subs feeling the
hot
I'm still sad though this game could
have been a fun position 96 good move Oh
a 96 ridiculously strong move because
he's attacking two things it's about
time to resign but I have Bishop h6
check and then I have Bishop a6
and both my bishops are just stuck on
the side
and he's going to just play b4 b5 and
drop the bishop
or that
just Estelle
to do
I'm thinking here
not gonna resign yet I'm thinking
you
you
oh shoot I lost the bishop
other bishop
yeah okay
time's resign good game
I was hoping for stalemate but yeah he
is smart enough not not to fall into it
a good game that was a really
interesting game I'm not even upset
let's go and analyze I just want to see
the opening because this is something I
play as White's I know that the g5 is
maybe slightly dubious if white is
really well-prepared
the g5 that's here but this is okay this
is Lee chest database let's go to
masters database I'm pretty sure there's
a poll card game
I forget who she was playing though no
there's actually several strong oh wait
a minute
g5 22 games yeah Polgara against Godfrey
cough Miroslava ch played the scratch of
so it actually scores decently for black
hey thanks for the comment a menu la
that's nice to hear
would like to play me
I'm gonna do another viewer challenge
stream soon but unfortunately I think
this is a last alas game because I'm
tired it's it's already 12:40 that was a
long game just want to see this opening
yeah h3 most common move Oh even play h3
he played D 3 and then h3 no this was a
strong response game kept going I really
wanted to play rook take a 2
in this position I'm seeing this
evaluation that I've already lost let's
it's crazy because I like during the
game I didn't feel lost it just felt
like a really complex position
I guess White's pieces are just better
okay I want to go for a run to do some
physical activity thanks everyone for
watching I haven't checked the
viewership today but
I'm decent turnouts thanks everyone for
subbing thank you so much to people who
gifted Suggs toilet noggin and Nathan
Matt ninety-nine subs I think we'll
celebrate a hundred subs for the next
stream so no one sub right now unless
you wanna you want to I mean can't stop
people so I'm taking off see you guys in
the future oh it's a sub captain Sano 89
the 100 subscriber okay well now I guess
I have to celebrate
but I'll be celebrating with a run
itself and Starbucks Starbucks happy
hour
okay bye guys